Matt Reeves' "The Batman" offers up a major
character reveal during the film's final moments,
and this is your last spoiler warning before
we get into it.
What if we told you there was supposed to
be an even bigger, more pivotal scene at Arkham
Asylum much earlier in the movie involving
this surprise prisoner that got cut?
As Reeves put it while speaking to IGN,
"The movie is not an origin tale for Batman,
but it's his early days.
It really is an origin tale for the rogues
gallery."
Not only is this "origin tale" sentiment applicable
to the character we meet in the third act,
but it also applies to the other antagonists
we meet earlier in the movie.
Over the course of the nearly three-hour runtime
"The Batman" boasts, moviegoers are introduced
to the Riddler, Penguin, and Catwoman, followed
by the widely-talked-about Arkham reveal of
Joker, played by Barry Keoghan.
In Reeves' Batman universe, the character
is currently locked up for some unknown reason
and, as the director tells IGN, is only in
his early "infancy" as the Clown Prince of
Crime.
In fact, the big reveal fans get at the end
of "The Batman" was actually supposed to be
a "companion" scene to a much bigger breakout
moment involving the character at Arkham Asylum
that would have occurred earlier in the movie.
The scene would have featured Robert Pattinson's
Dark Knight coming to consult with the Joker
at Arkham in an attempt to profile the Riddler
in the hopes of stopping him.
Reeves told IGN,
"The reason that Joker's in the movie is there
was actually another scene that was earlier.
The scene that was not in the movie, the scene
that this is really the companion to…
It's a scene where Batman is so unnerved because
the Riddler is writing to him, and he figures
he's got to profile this killer.
So, he goes to see another killer that he's
clearly had an experience with in these first
two years.
And this killer in this story is not yet the
character that we come to know."
As Reeves describes it, DC villains will often
"declare their alter-egos" in response to
Batman's existence and arrival in Gotham throughout
the comics, so this was a direction that he
wanted to go in, too.
"We have a Joker that's not yet the Joker."
As for why the scene involving Batman and
Joker was cut, the filmmaker did not say,
but he did reveal what Warner Bros. has planned
for it in the future.
Reeves insisted during his interview with
IGN that fans would get to see his deleted
Joker and Batman scene at some point in the
future.
Whether the scene will appear in a director's
cut like "Zack Snyder's Justice League" or
perhaps a Blu-ray/DVD feature of some sort
remains to be seen.
"[The scene] will release at some point.
In the scene that you'll see in the future,
you'll see that we worked on what he'd look
like, and he's kind of held in this kind of
very suspenseful way, away from you visually."
As for what's next for the iconic DC baddie,
should he pop up again in the future is anybody's
guess.
But one thing we know for sure is that Reeves
has big plans for him, telling IGN,
"He's eventually going to declare himself
as a clown, declare himself as the Joker."
YouTube users who watched the interview and
heard this declaration were excited to learn
that Reeves was taking things slow but serious
with the character, especially since it gave
Paul Dano's Riddler more time to shine in
"The Batman."
One user wrote,
"I'm actually glad they cut the scene because
if they showed him in the middle of the movie,
people would just think about Joker and ignore
Paul Dano's excellent Riddler performance,"
Another commenter noted how excited they were
to see a future Joker after enjoying the look
of another member of Batman's Rogues Gallery
that popped up in "The Batman,"
"Keeping him in the shadows gives them more
time to work on his look, which is being designed
by the same people who did the Penguin."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.